[music]
Hello and good morning. Uh thank you all
for joining us. Uh what an exciting time
to talk about uh robotics, to talk about
physical AI. Uh we have a wonderful
guest here to lead us through what uh
what he is doing. Jeff Cardinis is the
CEO and founder of Apptronic. Uh we're
going to delve into the company. We're
going to delve into some of the
competitive dynamics. We're going to
delve into humanoids and the evolution
into this marketplace. But I think we're
going to kick off with a video. If we
can get that started first, that'd be
great.
But why some say the moon?
[music]
Why choose this as our goal?
And they may well ask, why climb the
highest mountain?
Why, 35 years ago, fly [music] the
Atlantic?
>> Hello, Apollo. Hello, Jeff.
>> We choose to go to the moon.
We choose to go to the moon and do the
other things. Not because they are easy,
but because they are hard.
Five
3 2 1.
We have liftoff.
Apollo landed.
>> Great. Great. Very nice. Thank you for
being with us. Uh we both had exciting
trips. Yours sounded a little bit more
exciting than mine.
>> Yeah, it was quite the adventure.
>> Oh,
>> we're glad that you made it in one
piece. Um, why don't we start off with
the origin story? You started Appronic.
There may be some people who here who
don't know about Appronic. You started
Appronic out of the University of Texas.
Tell us about how you got the idea for
it, how you ended up founding the
company, and how it's been evolving
since, please.
>> Yeah, sounds great. First of all, it's
great to be here. Uh, it's always
amazing to be at these robotics
conferences. It still feels like we're
at the early days of the industry
overall where we can all fit into a a
small room like this. Um, Appcharting
started officially in 2016. So, we're a
spin out of the University of Texas at
Austin. And I started the company with a
professor at the University of Texas, a
guy named Dr. Luis Centis. Uh, Luis had
a long history in humanoid robots, was
coming out of Stanford, um, and started
the human- centered robotics lab. And
so, uh, we all met when I was in
graduate school. But the genesis of the
company for me was really a fascination
I've had since I was a kid with
computing and computers. And my lens
coming into graduate school was what's
the equivalent of the personal computer
revolution for my generation. And so my
view is that general purpose robots and
humanoid robots in particular are
effectively like the personal computer.
And if you take that analogy, it feels
like we're in the early 80s and we're at
the birth of a new industry. Um, we've
been at this for over a decade. We built
a lot of different robots. We built now
10 iterations of humanoid robots. Almost
20 unique robots. We've done humanoids,
exoskeletons, and mobile manipulators.
Um, and it feels like we're just getting
started.
>> Great. Great. You've used this analogy.
I want to delve into it just a little
bit more. For those of you who may not
remember, in the early 80s, the PC era
was just getting kicked off. There were
only a handful of things you could do
with them. You could do spreadsheets.
You could do word processing. What are
the parallels with robots do you think
at this point? And I think it was Steve
Jobs who said a PC will be kind of a
bicycle for your mind. What's that view
of where robots can go in the future?
>> Yeah, I mean I think it's it's right
there. So I think we're in the early8s.
We're in the spreadsheet word processing
phase of the game. My view is for
robotics it's going to happen in three
major stages. U general purpose robots
for if you will. So stage one was
technical feasibility. So, first proving
out that we could actually do it. When
we got started, a lot of people said,
"It's too hard to get robots to walk.
You're never going to get them able to
move." And now it's been interesting
because now people kind of handwave this
idea that robots can break dance uh
right in front of you. That's that's
seen as being easy. The next phase and
the phase that we're in right now is the
commercial viability stage. And this is
I use the analogy we're in the word
processing spreadsheet phase of the
game. So we're proving the initial
applications to prove that these robots
are useful and that they're commercially
viable, that we have real business cases
around them. Once we prove that out,
we'll very quickly get into the
commercial scaling phase. And I think
sometimes people are conflating those
two uh stages overall. Um what you're
going to see is the same thing's going
to happen. So three phases in my view
for commercialization. The way that we
think of it is back of house, front of
house, and the home. So today we're in
really the back of house phase. Uh
that's largely gated by safety and what
the models can do. So what gets us into
front of house is we start to solve
safety. The models get better and now we
can have these robots interacting with
and around humans doing really useful
things out in the world. And once we
have that, then it's the time that
everybody's waiting for. Uh robots that
do all of your dishes and do your
laundry and do all the things that you
don't want to do. So robots in the home.
>> Great. Great. I want to pause for a
minute to talk about Robot Park. Uh you
just opened up Robot Park. Uh Jeff's
facilities are in Texas. Of course,
you're manufacturing in Texas. This is
an old Dell facility, I think, that you
guys have been using to do some test
runs of robots. What what's going on
there? What do you hope to accomplish
with Robot Park?
>> Yeah. Well, so Robot Park was a dream
that I had at the very beginning. Uh, I
would I would go get beers with my
co-founder, Nick, another graduate
student, uh, who was coming out of
Luis's lab. And we would dream up what
the future should look like. And one of
the things that I believe is we want the
future to be optimistic and exciting.
And I think a lot of people are really
scared about robots and how they're
going to have an impact on society. Uh,
we have movies like Terminator to thank
for uh, the fears we have in the US
around robots. And the idea behind Robot
Park is what if we created a place that
was really exciting and inspiring, a
place where we're building and we're
also showcasing the future. So we had
these big dreams about what it will be
in the future. And I called it Willy
Wonka's robot factory. That was kind of
the the north star. And what it looks
like today though is it looks like
basically a data factory. So you have a
factory where we're building the robots
and now we have a data factory. Uh it's
effectively 90,000 square feet. We have
a depot where we're repairing robots and
then we're doing large scale data
collection of different sorts inside of
robot park. So, uh it looks fairly
unglamorous on the outside today. It's
basically a warehouse. Uh but in the
future, who knows uh where it'll go.
>> Wow. I like the idea of Willy Wonka's
robot factory. That sounds like a great
vision. You have to invite us when that
uh when that gets off. Okay. We'd love
to come. Um
>> let's talk about the shape of of your
robots. make the case for humanoids is
as we talked earlier as we were
preparing there are a lot of robotics
companies that have been quite
successful with alternatives where they
try to do one thing the physical arm we
talked about Fanic Phen the Japanese
company that has been quite successful
in manufacturing in particular why do
you think there's this opportunity for
the humanoid shape in particular what's
the appeal of that
>> yeah so the frame that I had coming into
robotics was that if you looked at
robotics, it hadn't really scaled. This
was around 2015 when I was coming into
robotics. And the big question was why?
And the real challenge that I saw when I
went out and talked to different
operators and people that had been in
robotics for a long time was really
around systems integration and limited
functionality for what robots can do. So
I had this frame coming in that was if
robots are going to scale, we need
something like a personal computer, a
generalpurpose platform that we can have
ecosystems of developers that could
actually build on top of. And so you
sort of work from first principles, you
work up from there. Where you start is
this idea of versatility. So
traditionally, we had special purpose
robots that did one thing. And my pitch
in the very early days was we're going
to move from single robots that do
single tasks to building one robot that
can do thousands of different tasks. A
robot that can do anything. So you start
with versatility, but the challenge tied
to versatility is that it's very
expensive traditionally to integrate
these robots and customize a workflow
around what a robot can do. So tied to
versatility is this idea of
retrofitability. What if I don't have
this massive systems integration
challenge? What if I can just retrofit a
robot into an environment already
designed around humans? So,
retrofitability, versatility, those two
things came together. And that was sort
of the precursor to humanoids. Now you
have modern AI and now you have the
third component which is how do you get
a robot to do thousands of different
things. And it turns out that the human
form is really relevant to these modern
ways of training AI where we can take
data from humans doing things whether
it's teley operation or video data or
sensorizing humans and we can use that
to build models that then can control
robots that are the same morphology. So
you have those three things coupled
together versatility at the foundation
retrofitability and then the ability to
learn from humans. And I think that's
what's going to drive humanoid robots to
be something like the personal computer.
>> Let's talk a bit about that intersection
of AI and robots. You do have this
opportunity to do training now in a way
that we just didn't have even two or
three uh years ago. How do you
anticipate robots will be able to take
advantage of the of these um this this
intelligence that we're getting through
AI? And when you're talking about
training these robots, what does that
involve? like what what kind of data do
you need to be able to teach a robot to
work in a factory, never mind come into
your home and clean your home and do
your dishes?
>> Yeah. So, on the AI side, we've been
very fortunate to partner with I believe
are some of the best minds in the world.
I think I see some of them here. uh the
folks at Google DeepMind uh we announced
a research collaboration with them
almost two years ago now and have been
really working working to push the
state-of-the-art for intelligence on uh
on these robots. The question around
data uh I think is interesting because
we're at an exciting time for the
industry as a whole. So the analogy that
I use is for a long time in robotics we
had a ceiling that we were hitting in
terms of performance and that ceiling
has now been removed and now there's
several different approaches that are
now sort of moving beyond what robots
could do before and depending on the
company or the entrepreneur they'll tell
you that their approach is going to be
the thing that will take us to the
promised land of sort of general
intelligence. Um, I think the juryy's
still out and one of the beauties of
robotics is showing versus telling,
right? You can actually show and
demonstrate what these robots can do.
But there's three basic approaches to
collecting data. So the first uh is
collecting data directly off the robot.
Uh that's generally what you see today.
That's teley operation. The second is
collecting data off of humans. There's a
variety of different ways you can
collect data off of humans. Whether it's
video data, which is much easier, or
sensorizing humans, you'll see uh
egocentric human data where you put
cameras or other type of sensors on
humans. And then kind of the final
frontier, the thing that I think a lot
of people are excited about is synthetic
data or data that comes from the
computer, which is uh very scalable. Um
and there holds a lot of promise there.
And I think generally what you're seeing
today in the field is a combination of
those different formats. Um and we're
seeing great results. Okay. You you've
talked about how the home is probably
one of the last places you're going to
see humanoid robots. There are a lot of
issues. I think you alluded to the fact
you don't want a humanoid robot stepping
on your cat.
>> Yeah. Out of why why is the home so
difficult?
>> So, one of the ways that we used to talk
about what was happening in robotics is
we would say this this phrase of
structured to unstructured application.
So, you can think of you're going on
this sort of paradigm from easy to
harder. Um, if you think about that in
robotics, the more controlled an
environment is, the easier it is, the
less controlled it is, the more chaotic
that environment is, the harder it is to
get a robot to do something because we
want to predict uh their actions. And if
you think about unstructured
applications, uh the home is the most
unstructured, chaotic environment. So,
depending on where you live, you know,
some homes are messier than others, some
homes have stairs, some have small
children that just so happen to be very
excited about robots. uh some have small
pets and so there's a lot of variability
and the home is very chaotic and because
of that I think the liability is going
to be very high in the home and we have
to get our feet under us as a uh you
know pun intended I guess uh we have to
get our feet under us as an industry to
really start to drive more um
predictability in terms of what the
robots are can do to make sure that
they're safe. So really safety is the
gate to scale in all of these
applications and uh we're still in the
early days and so it's going to start in
these simple applications starting in
manufacturing and logistics then you're
going to see areas like healthcare,
hospitality and retail and then
eventually the home but it's probably
not going to be so linear. I think
you'll see early adopters and you start
you see some great companies that are
already trying to tackle it today and uh
I I sort of joke I salute them uh for
their uh for their courage
>> but I also want to be mindful about the
challenges that are in front of us as
well.
>> I see. I see. I I want to ask about the
scale of the industry as you see it at
this point. I was reading a report from
Bernstein where they were talking about
50 million robots in 2050. So roughly
around the scale of the uh the auto
industry, big, not enormous. Elon Musk
has been quite bold talking about
billions of robots. We're going to all
have two of them, two humanoids to kind
of help us out. Where where do you see
this going in say 10 years or 20 years?
>> Yeah, I think I think in 10 years we
will have millions of robots. Um I I
sort of will we'll leave the predictions
in some way to uh the the industry
analysts but you know we we will have
robots in every facet of life over the
next 10 years including in the home. Um,
you know, when I got started and
thinking about humanoids, it, you know,
I was one of the most ambitious, you
know, people that I had met, right? I
was coming from Texas and thinking about
doing humanoid robots and I was saying
we'll have millions of humanoid robots
uh, in the coming years and then as Elon
got into the game, it was billions at
first and then it turned into tens of
billions and I think the number is 20
billion now. So,
>> it depends on what time horizon you want
to take. uh but we will have lots of
robots and I do think this will be uh
the biggest industry of our time. I
think similar to computers or
automobiles, robots are what's coming
next and they're going to be an everyday
part of our life.
>> Okay, let's talk a bit about geopolitics
and the competition among different
countries. Um we've written a fair bit
about how the Chinese robotics industry
right now is quite you know quite ahead
of the US uh industry. There are
companies like Unitry that are making
lots of progress. You probably saw Honor
had a robot that ran a marathon and did
very well. In China, they have
kickboxing contests. They're doing
millions of robots right now and the US
is a bit behind. How do you see that
competition playing out at this point?
And how important is it for the US or
Europe to have a feasible robot
industry?
>> Yeah, I mean, look, my view is that, you
know, robots are the space race of our
time. So the way that I kind of think
about robotics is it's the
infrastructure layer that you build
society on top of. So robots are going
to be a part of every industry uh and
growing over the coming decades. Um I
think it's going to be really important
that that every country uh the US in
particular has a vibrant robotics sector
because this is going to drive national
competitiveness and national security uh
over the coming decades. The history of
robotics I think is really interesting
because this goes back a really long
time.
>> So the very first written attempts at at
building something like a humanoid robot
were in 3rd century BC China. Uh so as
humans we thought about building
humanoid robots before we thought about
computers or cars or airplanes. This
idea that we could build mechanical
versions of ourselves that would do all
the things that we don't want to do. If
you look at the US, the US invented the
very first industrial robot. was called
the Unimate Arm. It went into a General
Motors factory in 1961.
And the story that Jeff Bernstein tells
is that we had over a hundred robotic
companies and component suppliers in the
US in the mid 1980s. And by the end of
the 80s, we basically had none. And so
went the the the reason for that was
there was a lot of fear about what
robots were going to do to jobs. But I
think the important thing to remember is
that for policy makers is so went the
robots. So too went all those
manufacturing jobs. By getting rid of
the robots, we didn't save the
manufacturing jobs. Actually the the
manufacturing jobs actually went to uh
countries like Japan that were heavy
adopters of industrial automation and of
robots. And so I think that's an
important lesson because as the as a
country we had an opportunity uh back in
the 80s we sort of missed out on the
first big race. And I think this this
current race is going to dwarf uh what
we saw previously and it's important for
us to play a role and I think there's
several folks that would disagree with
the idea that we're behind uh as you
said in your in your question but I do
think uh it's going to be a global race
and I think it's anyone's to win right
now.
>> Okay. Uh it's a very good point. I think
you and other proponents have argued
that when you have humanoids, humanoid
robots, if you have two per person, if
you begin to get into the hundreds of
millions, you disconnect economic growth
from the human population in a very
important way. You can have economic
growth without more humans, which seems
like it's critical for many of these
things in the future. I know I we're
running low on time. I'm not going to
get through half my questions, but I
want to finish with one last one. I know
you've uh talked with Washington a bit
about a national robotic strategy. You
would like the United States and perhaps
Europe also to have a more coherent
national robotic strategy. What would
you like to see in that strategy?
>> Yeah, I mean to me it's supply and
demand, right? So, how do we how do we
um help to build the industry that we
need? That's going to look like
incentives at the R&D level and and
other areas. And then on the demand
side, how do we incentivize uptake of
robots on the other end as well? So, uh,
we've helped to, um, contribute to the
association for advancing automation. If
you go to their their site and I see
Brian Heater in the in the in the front,
uh, you can see the national robotics
strategy that I would say the entire
sector is is behind and helping to to
push forward. I think if you compare the
US to China, China has had a national
robotic strategy since 2021.
uh they have more uptake of robots than
the rest of the world combined with four
times the population and they have a $1
138 billion sort of national robotics
fund and so our question to policy
makers is this is what China is doing
what is our answer to that right and our
answer can't be nothing we can't put our
head in the sand we saw what happened to
our manufacturing sector when we sort of
I would argue fumbled the ball back in
the 1980s what are we going to do now
and how do we get in front of this and
sort of the bare minimum of that is
let's at least build a national robotic
strategy um that we can sort of think
about where we want to aim in the
future.
>> Okay, I think we're out of time. We
could go on and do this for a long time.
Thank you, Jeff Cardinius. Everybody,
thank you.
>> Thanks for having me.
[applause] Good.